Votre compagnie
Sierra Asset Management
a reçu un paiement
de 22,5 millions de dollars
de SNC-Lavalin?
C'était pour autre chose!
Ça n'avait rien à voir
avec l'attribution du contrat du CUSM!
Comment est-ce possible?
Pour quel travail SNC
vous verse-t-elle cette somme?
Nous étions en pourparlers
pour que je travaille comme consultant
pour développer des projets en Afrique
J'ai dit alors aux dirigeants de SNC
que je demandais 5 millions par année
pour un contrat de 5 ans
Mon travail consistait à trouver
des occasions d'affaires.
Vous savez, un seul contrat peut
rapporter 1 milliard à la compagnie
J'ai été surpris qu'ils soient intéressés
par mon offre.
Mais compte tenu des objectifs
qu'ils voulaient atteindre
dans les pays en développement
et des contrats qu'ils visaient
ce n'était pas si cher pour eux.
À qui avez-vous demandé 5 millions
par année?
Je ne veux pas le dire à cette étape.
À Jacques Lamarre?
Je ne répondrai pas à cette question
parce que je suis impliqué
dans des poursuites en ce moment.
Et parce que j'entreprendrai moi-même
des démarches légales en temps et lieu.
Il s'est dit beaucoup de choses
à la commission Charbonneau
mais je ne suis pas prêt à faire de même.
Juste pour que ce soit  clair :
vous vous attendiez à recevoir 5 millions
par année de SNC comme consultant ?
Oui
Et cet argent vous serait versé
après l'appel d'offres de l'hôpital?
Exact
Pour des projets et du travail
que vous aviez fait avant ?
Pour des choses que j'ai faites avant,
pendant et après.
Nous étions toujours en discussion.